you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer I'm gonna try three more
puzzles and just share my thoughts along
the way so alright and this one it's
white to move and it feels like we're
close to having some fork against the
black King two Knights around a bishop
here as well that could be doing
something forcing the King onto a square
maybe so that a knight could deliver a
fork or some some pin and skewer type of
situation I've seen puzzles like these
before its sheer calculation skill
something that I lack so okay let's see
okay checking moves what do we have to
start this night he's on the same color
square as this guy so he could give
check a couple ways Knight here Knight
here and pawn push all give check
having said that actually looking first
at the black side this Queen if black
has an opportunity to move this Queen
can't really do so much she can't move
and do something so great to the white
side there's no checking move at least
there is however a Queen move here that
would pin the bishop and it seems like
she'd be quite inaccessible to a knight
fork or a bishop move at that point
since the bishop would be pin and if
she's on this square she could she has a
ton of other options so I think the idea
will be to be quite forceful not even
allow black a moment to run away with
the Queen to this square or she also has
a eight if she wanted to go there so
anyhow I think it'll be a checking move
to start okay now which checking move of
these two Knight moves
I don't feel that it would be this one
I'm sorry this one right here since he's
not essential night here there's King
here and then I don't see what the great
follow-up would be this might be the
first one actually this check why would
it be that what makes you think that it
would be that move I am Not sure okay
pawn check not even sure where to start
with this okay how many options is a
king have let's just say it's black
smooth maybe that's a way I can start
with this one if it's black smooth Black
has three different squares the King
could be going to if pawn push here the
King still has three squares one two
only when they then have four squares
there'd be a new square available so if
pawn check there's four different King
moves you would have to be calculating
if the knight gives a check there would
be three there's a lot to calculate here
the King is gonna have very many options
regardless which move you run with to
give check hmm okay let's see
hmmm this is tough
if paan push if the King goes to any of
these two maybe this is a good one to
start with in fact I was saying if pawn
push here the King has four squares
available D 5 C 6 d 7 e 7 but let's
eliminate 2 right away if pawn push the
King goes to either of these two Knight
here is a fork of the king and queen
game over all right so pawn push the
King can't go to these two however he
could go here or here there's probably
something seriously wrong with the King
being so close to the white pieces by
going to this square now what would be
so wrong with that
well for one there's another check of a
pond and if King takes pawn we have this
fork if that's even the follow-up but
I'm just saying if pond at if pawn push
King here pawn push with check the King
would have to play here here actually
hmm maybe there's something else even if
pawn push King here now this Bishop
might even play a role with some trick
with like Knight takes pawn here with
the fork not quite working just yet but
there might be something to some pin if
the King is playing on this diagonal
Bishop g2 stuff how to get this black
Queen we're still running with this one
pawn push
hmm pawn push if King here eliminated
these two working on the d5 King d5 move
in response to c5 c5 King d5 this Knight
can't move and give check this night
could I doubt it be a knight move though
some knight move and then there's King
takes pawn on c5 he's running away in
this direction kind of discount that
variation pawn push King d5 pawn c4
check King in d4 there's King d4 and
there's King here also if King d4
oh man I don't like these puzzles this
this specific one right here on plush
King d5 pawn push King d4 mm it's too
tough for me too tough
c5 King d5 c4 mm I'm just not seeing it
there's something other than pawn push I
already abandoned that
who else has those thoughts thank you
what you all just quit I don't know
let's show me the solution how about
that let's move on to the next puzzle
ah man pawn push what if the King runs
away in this direction it's y'all
smarter now c5 King here maybe I could
forget about that because of this bill
oh man what's the good follow-up after
that if c5 King here
well great things do you have available
now Knight check who cares
King here now what that's a bunch of
garbage this move I think I'm setting
myself up to sound really foolish if
that is the first move all right
stay tuned um I'm not sure what else to
even consider Knight check here
hang on night check here King here I
think I might check here King here
night check the King can't go here still
because of this night move so night
check on this square if the King plays
here
what do you even do oh no that wouldn't
be yet
I was thinking night checking here
Knight takes pawn that's definitely not
it the Queen gets to take with the check
Wow
feels like this should be it maybe the
King is quite limited that's this is the
most forcing I guess you could say
Knight a5 King here to e6
oh man night check King here night check
on d4 with the fork pawn takes Bishop h3
check this is very difficult for me to
visualize Bishop checks so what King
here I'm not seeing the solution this
one I've devoted it's way too much time
to it I'm just gonna make him little bit
I know it's wrong no it's right
oh man makes me feel really good right I
I think this might be it yeah it is
correct but I just I don't know the
reason why it's not a good feeling not a
good feeling Knight check here if pawn
takes he doesn't have to take though he
doesn't have to take that's that that's
the problem I mean he does have to take
in that position I'm sorry knight Knight
here pawn takes but after after like a
bishop check the King could just run
away you don't have to take here if
Knight check pawn takes Bishop check if
Queen takes Knight takes f4 would be a
fork but the black isn't forced into
taking like that
is there some there might be some sneaky
Bishop to G to move oh my goodness
Knight check here pawn takes Bishop g2
are you kidding me
it's Bishop g2 oh my goodness that is it
ah this is a ridiculously tough problem
for me
these calculate these strictly
calculation problems that is correct
what a quiet move and now you're forced
in doing something and then that's it
okay now you take the Queen all right oh
that was one that's causing me a
headache
mmm okay I think at the start this video
I said I was gonna do three puzzles that
one wore me out so I'm just gonna do one
more let's try one more
that was very taxing on me I must say
okay yeah and you know what to be honest
like those are ones that I usually skip
I just I I don't know like I I like ones
that are once I get I didn't really mean
to say that what am I trying to say I
like ones that are maybe a bit more
realistic like this one this you could
really see this one in an actual game
but then again there are these
constructed end game problems like a
self stalemate one that was composed
certain composed ones I like but I I
just don't like those types of problems
but this one seems quite realistic let's
see what we could do with this one black
to move here okay well I'd really like
to move this pawn and give a check and
pick up this rook but how do you get
this clean out of here okay
let's work on that might be doable in
fact you could play here force the Queen
off of this square but you are investing
a full
do just that alright so this is a
candidate move there are no checking
moves to start with so the next great
big punch you could be throwing at white
would be to attack the Queen if there is
a queen and there is rook c2 would do
just that
and you're pretty much as white locked
into taking the rook okay and then if
pawn push that is check but do you have
a great follow up after King here I mean
you can get the Brooke back I mean
you're investing rook to get a rook back
and give up a valuable pawn however
however maybe Queen here is a
possibility for if Queen takes Queen now
the pawn promotes oh I'm sorry now the
pawn moves with check picks up the rook
with check and produces a new queen
uh-huh I think that's it Queen here
Queen takes pawn push with check
followed by taking the rook getting a
new queen and you're up material you got
the full rook if Queen here and then
rook to e1 trying to maintain the
Queen's position in some way there's
rook here it's also maybe worth noting
there's a flight Square for the King in
case this night ends up moving there's a
not a good follow up like if the Queen's
are off the board there's not going to
be some back rank mate
so Queen here I'm trying to look at now
some alternatives I'm pretty sure Queen
takes I know what I'm doing however
after Queen here let's say I was just
gonna say what if Knight here you just
take the knight
you're still on the Queen Queen takes
Queen same story pawn push take the rook
next
so I've Queen here if the knight moves
to defend the Queen by way of c1 you
take the night and if Knight here to
defend the Queen
I think the ensuing move rook c2 is
gonna be quite strong same story with
Queen here rook e1 rook c2 as a
follow-up I'm pretty sure that this is
at queena a - let's go with that I've
invested enough time and that is in fact
correct and we are having Knight to f4
and I believe that this is the follow up
or up to C - all right take the Queen
the knight takes and you could play rook
c2 but then there's King here believe
you have to kick the Queen immediately
now there are some checks rook c2 if
Brooke c2 right now there is a rook
check King here it's important that
there's this flight square there's a
queen check here but then after a block
there's some serious threats to the back
rank here Queen a1 or b1 initially I was
thinking the rook could maybe come over
here to be giving check and maybe he
could actually the knight could take but
there's Queen f2 Queen f2 to e1 stuff
like that but Queen a1 to be queen to a
1 or b1 is probably good enough so I'm
pretty sure Brooke c2 is it and that is
correct there is a check that's an only
move Queen check and you block with this
pawn
don't forget about that on passant stuff
and that is actually it that's the end
of this problem there's now not going to
be a good solution to the Queen playing
here - a1 or b1 to deliver mate or even
advancing this pawn with check and then
promoting on the next
okay yeah that first one really wore me
out and I'm not gonna do a third problem
in this one so feel free to share how
you did with these two problems and I'll
catch in the next video take care bye
you